who else is completely obsessed with all
of us are dead countless hours of
planning and rehearsals combined with
freaky effects and stunts galore make
for some riveting moments in this korean
drama series
let's go behind the scenes
i don't understand
how can you still be like this
luck
you only get one shot
okay well in this case it wasn't so dire
but the director did try to capture
multiple scenes in as long a continuous
single shot as they could just to amp up
the whole zombies taking over vibes the
cafeteria invasion with zombies raging
on mass was rehearsed for hours with
every single move laid out this wasn't
just a few people to organize though
this involved hundreds of actors and
crew members with the whole affair being
so messy some of the equipment was
actually protected behind the scenes
with plastic covers zombie business is
messy but when it brings results like
this well it's all worth it
with zombies around anything is possible
the all of us are dead actors not only
had to learn a ton of fight choreography
they had to figure out how to safely do
it while hooked up to wires with the
help of a harness and experts behind the
scenes they were really able to make
those battles pop whenever a hit was
made no matter what position the
performer would be in the riggers could
control what we see on screen to make
sure the fight was carried out properly
safely and let's be honest epically a
swift kick is all you need oh and that
crash mat to ensure a soft landing
[Music]
it's okay now
how far down is it
we're not too sure hanging upside down
and dropping headfirst was what these
performers expected when they first
auditioned for the netflix korean drama
series but it's certainly what they got
this was one of the more extensive and
dangerous stunts to pull off with the
full blue screen room being the only
place to pull it off so the cg could
look realistic this duo leap of faith
was safety equipment central and thanks
to some serious guts from the performers
that's gotta hurt
luckily there wasn't too much pain for
these zombie brittle actors in order to
make the show look as grounded in
reality as possible loads of practical
effects were key we're talking fake
blood freaky makeup and super detailed
prosthetic pieces before filming could
start powers had to be spent in that
makeup chair this makeup and prosthetics
team had a lot of work on their plate
with the significant amount of actors
needing all that zombifying and of
course the final touch preset fake blood
keeping that liquid held in while
waiting for the cameras to roll isn't
the most glamorous part of the job but
it's so worth it for the creepy effect
even if everyone in the world but us has
turned into zombies
we can't fall into despair
this set is on fire
why rely on vfx when you can create your
own special real effects right on set
luckily it was a small one and kept
under control but fire extinguishers
were still at the ready behind the
cameras the realistic detail added a lot
to the environment since they were
relying on just blue screens for filming
this made the actors jobs a bit easier
as well as having something tangible to
actually work with and consider while
performing who the hell are you
you come from the one heart club get
ready for a major face plant this
particular stunt wasn't performed super
high in the air because of just how
risky it was safety training was the
word before rigging in mats were put in
place and ready to shoot because the
drop happened so quickly the harness and
wires were specially designed to allow
the swift action without risking injury
while it was a tricky one to perform the
move gave us such a heightened sense of
just how crazy this show would really be
oh and all the damage to the face that
was just makeup no real face plants here
luckily
over and over and over again
seriously this wasn't a one shot wonder
the all of us are dead team went take
after take through the real window with
all the needed safety measures in place
of course who wouldn't want to spend
their time on set tied up and hanging
upside down waist and ankle connections
were necessary for all that flailing of
course if all else failed there was at
least that stick there were a lot of
spotters and mats all around but that
didn't make the filming experience any
less terrifying for the actor signing on
to this series meant being ready for
anything and being brave enough to
perform your own stunts mission
accomplished
[Music]
it wasn't technically a real school but
it did the trick instead of filming in
an already standing building the crew
for the netflix show built a four-story
high 100 meter long wall that acted as
the school facade and does it work you
bet it does
this was really the only option for the
team because they wanted to be able to
film so many stunts that allowed them to
cater the set to their needs it was a
massive undertaking and so worth it we'd
never have known these freaky school
window moments were filmed anywhere
other than an actual school
are you
as if the series weren't hectic enough
books shouldn't hurt but when a load of
them come falling out of a bookshelf
then the damage can be pretty severe the
bookshelves on set were hard at work
going from standing upright to tipped in
order to capture the attack of the
novels simple but clever and oh so
effective in this case producing the
effect practically made the most sense
for both the actors experience and
getting the right framing anyone else
thinking these bookshelves are giving
serious drinking bird vibes
it's drinking the water this is the
greatest invention in the world is it
the all of us are dead set or the video
shoot for thriller who can tell hours
and hours were spent getting into their
zombie bodies and learning just how they
would behave and move in the world of
the show
a choreographer collaborated with the
actors to see how they moved best and
together they built the physical
language of their creatures but the work
didn't stop there once the choreo itself
was done came the practice practice
practice if they weren't filming they
were probably rehearsing because so much
action needed to happen precisely so the
show could finish filming on time and on
budget
what's that sound i don't know
first aid kits on set are key luckily no
one was badly injured even being sent
through glass over and over thanks to
the magic of sugar glass it makes that
satisfying break sound and shatters
perfectly but all safely who knew
those window panels were replaced every
time they tried to capture the shots so
by the end of the shoot well there was a
strong need for a cleanup outside the
window
when accidents turn good is there any
better feeling young chen young lost a
bit of control in the moment but it
wound up being perfect for the show when
he threw a music stand he hadn't been
paying much attention to where all the
filming equipment was and the stand
accidentally went catapulting into the
camera knocking the shield around the
lens right out of place and blacking out
the camera you can't make a more perfect
aesthetic choice when this kind of gold
lands right in your lap you run with it
and this crew did it well
hey hey cut it out stop it already
sometimes you've gotta kick it old
school fog lightning flashes cold wind a
perfect recipe for a spooky evening and
in all of us are dead the fright factor
came fully practical flashing different
colored lights a shockingly simple way
to imitate lightning the environment
does most of the work while the filming
crew gets to capture the magic as it
happens
they're here hurry up
[Music]
it's gory intense and on occasion can
make us a bit queasy but one thing is
for sure the show makes an impact their
practical effects game is out of this
world they've got the zombie universe
covered which behind the scenes shoot
would you like to see live on set